et oui le retrait de barkan s'accélère
nouveau transfert aux femmes à ce lundi
cette fois les soldats français quitte
la base de ménaka cyril payen vous avez
des informations l'armée française
devrait officialiser donc cette
information bon on parle oui
effectivement c'est tout frais et c'est
effectivement une information qu'on
avait depuis ce matin mais c'est
effectif c'est la der l'avant-dernière
emprise vous le disiez de cette grande
aventure antiterroriste française qui a
commencé en janvier 2013 qui va commence
à s'achever puisque ménaka est une
emprise près dans la région de gao qui
contenait des forces barca donc cette
force antiterroriste composée de sein de
ce composé de cinq mille hommes mais
également pour un tiers de la force
takouba cet embryon de f2 d'unités de
forces de formation de forces spéciales
européennes qui a fait long feu compte
tenu de la dégradation des relations
entre bamako et et paris donc
effectivement c'est sans doute
l'épilogué un conte convient et après
cet engagement français de plusieurs
années de près de 8 ans puisque on peut
penser que avant la fin du mois d'août
selon le ce que nous dit l'état major
français et bien c'est la grande emprise
de gao gao que l'on voit ici c'est une
danse et ménaka pardon gao c'est une
ville il ya plus de dix mille personnes
et on s'active assez rapidement il faut
le dire pour quitter cette emprise pour
terminer en fait tout ce qu'ils aient
une quelconque forme de relations
militaires ou de coopération avec un
mali qui ne veut plus de la france on le
sait le torchon brûle depuis de nombreux
mois maintenant et on sait quoi dur
redéploiement de ses soldats qui vont
rester il ya des soldats français qui
restait dans la zone alors si on en est
on utilisait tout à fait le verbiage de
l'état major français il s'agit d'une
raie articulations sous impulsion
d'ailleurs du président français en
avril en avril dernier qui avait dit
compte tenu de nos relations nous ne
sommes plus désirés c'est évidemment une
interprétation et bien on serait
articule donc très certainement et là
aussi on voit qu'il ya un terreau d'un
stade d'instabilité dans cette région on
pense au burkina faso notamment avec des
coups d'état avec beaucoup de flottement
de pouvoir et puis un sentiment
anti-français aussi grandissant il faut
le dire qu'il soit orchestrée ou pas
donc 1 un recentrage vers le niger pays
où il va y avoir effectivement une
concentration de des forces mais on
avance à pas à pas comptés puisque
évidemment tout ça va extrêmement vite
beaucoup plus vite que ce qui était
prévu bien qu'on parle d'un programme
doré articulations mais on sent très
très franchement que les français
tentent de quitter ce pays où ils sont
plus désirés merci beaucoup cyril pour
ces éléments